walking over here with my parents today
where's mom and dad
all right they're somewhere here and
they were saying what's hustle con I was
saying it's a conference for people that
don't know how to do anything
um so I'm here to be a cheerleader for
what do you do with your career if you
don't know how to do anything and the
first step is my belief is you're going
to need four things okay and the first
of those four is inspired by my hometown
sports hero Walter Payton and I call it
tenacity so I'm a Chicago boy and living
in New York right now but basically have
got this belief that pretty much
everything you need to know in life you
can learn from from being a Chicago
sports fan so I grew up the son of a
Hindu mother and a Christian father so I
didn't really have a religion I could
attach to growing up but I wanted to
believe in something so what I believe
in is the Cubs right there's really no
reason for hope but every year we still
believe that this is going to be our
year and we have a mecca that we go to
which is called Wrigley Field we commune
we have a spiritual gathering nothing
really goes that well but we come
together anyway just sort of kind of
like an organized religion way to think
about it so why I love Walter Payton is
that he had an unbelievable career every
touchdown he scored with about two
exceptions he handed the ball to the ref
and he's were my role model for the
first of four traits that you're going
to need which is tenacity which is a
relentless desire to win a tremendous
resilience in the face of uncertainty
and then when you do succeed you hand
the ball to the ref and after the game
you give credit to your teammates I
learned that from Walter the second
thing that you're going to need comes
from our names namesake the bonobo and I
call it the ability to evolve so can you
guys name the five great apes bonobos
orangutangs guerrillas I think I heard
chimps and what's the 5th
humans that was really good ok it takes
a long time to get to huge humans
usually but yes we are great apes with
opposable thumbs language fire and the
ability to gossip but no bows I would
argue are the most evolved in some ways
they've developed matriarchal societies
with no violent conflict and if you look
around the world today we could learn a
lot from their willingness to get along
with each other and how do they do it
they put their women in charge they
tolerate and celebrate gay and bisexual
behavior they have adult males who play
with their children all the way late
through adulthood they can be a bit of
pedophiles
so don't pay attention to that part
ignore that but this basically is the
future of the human species and it will
- at one part and so when you think
about the history of great apes if you
look at the Congo River
it separates bonobos from chimps and in
chimps you have a typical male
patriarchy played out a little bit like
Hamlet or Macbeth the number three chimp
teams up with the number two they topple
the number one really ugly things happen
in the night and everyone wakes up
screaming because the number one male
chimp has been killed or been dropped
down to a lower status and so I think
this is slowly what we're doing as human
beings which is we're evolving our
society to a gender parity a true
partnership between the genders and
we're treating minorities very
differently we have it's happening
slowly but 2015 was a big year in the
u.s. if you're gay or bisexual and so
when I think about evolutionary ability
I think that this is the core to which
you're going to need as a human being in
life it's going to be core to how you
build a great company is the ability to
evolve to learn to grow to change your
mind and I think it's the second key
ingredient after tenacity in becoming a
great entrepreneur the third thing that
you're going to need I call authenticity
and so this is me and Brian's Bailey my
co-founder in 2007 on the Inca Trail and
I like to say sometimes I think Brian is
the better entrepreneur of the two of us
not only did he create better fitting
men's pants but he then went in created
a second company after we had a
co-founder divorce in 2009 called trunk
club and did an amazing job job with a
trunk club and he deaf
fits into the hustle con mode and what
we brought to the party were two things
Brian bought these brought these amazing
better fitting pants his basic
observation was that pants don't really
fit right if they're American cut
they're too boxy if they're the European
cut they're too tight and so he
developed a pant that has a contoured
waistband and so if you ever take off
your belt and you see the way that your
belt curves as you wear it our pants is
built with that curvature in mind
in fact it's denim that I'm wearing if
you're looking to do some shopping today
it's called jetsedder denim it's got
that curvature in the waist it's got a
more tailored fit through the thigh and
we offer it across four different fit
silhouettes and then 40 sizes for each
of those and that's only made possible
with the digitally native model which
was what I brought to the party this
idea that brands would be built
digitally native and if you're a dork
like me and you like to read medium late
at night when you're trying to learn
from other great entrepreneurs I
recently wrote a note called digitally
native vertical brands from bonobos and
menswear Warby Parker and I wear casper
and tough to needle and mattresses
Chubby's and amazing men shorts ever
lain monic and andy interior define and
furniture air dollar shave club harry's
my opinion is these brands are the
future of how brands get built and we're
really proud that bonobos was the first
in 2007 we spent four years pioneering
that model and then we discovered wait a
second oh this model isn't that
profitable how do we actually make money
and we decided that there was going to
be a way to make great stores and the
stores are called guide shops raise your
hand if you've been to a bonobos guide
shop okay so we've got a lot of work to
do you come in you get fitted you get
styled we offer you more fitting size
choice than would ever be possible in
traditional retail environment we offer
you great customer service 1 2 1 think
of it like a mini Apple Genius Bar on a
day where Apple isn't that crowded and
we then ship you the product so we
removed from the equation the idea that
you need to walk out and do your own
fulfillment and what we put in is a lot
more fit a lot more choice a lot more
color a lot more print and a heck of a
lot better customer service and so our
authenticity for that is what's driven
this company and so don't think about a
company that's going to make you money
think about a company that you would do
in a world where there was no money and
you may be on the right track the last
thing that you're going to need is
magnetism in the magnetism to attract
talent and capital and anything the
company needs at all times and this is
easy to do with the beginning when it's
a bright-eyed dream it's hard to do
later when you actually discover that
things don't go exactly as you planned
and you go through difficult times and
you go through moments where you don't
think you're going to make it and you
have to somehow summon enough self
belief that you're going to make it at
the same time as you reconcile the doubt
of the issues that you're facing and in
the midst of that attract more people
retain the people that you have and if
need be the capital to your venture and
so these four things together I call no
I in team and so this is a picture of me
and my dad who's the most selfless
person that I know let our family as a
great dad and never really felt like he
had to take credit never felt like he
was gonna do anything but take out the
garbage clean the kitchen after my mom
cooked dinner and this selflessness is
fundamental to the humility that people
really want to follow and I learned it
for my dad so please give it up for him
he's in the audience here today
what my dad's not good at is raising
money he's a history teacher
so let's talk about how do you raise
money so I have learned a lot about this
because I'm the founding CEO of bonobos
I'm a board member at four other brands
including interior define which is a
digital native furniture brand out of
Chicago Manik and Andy which I'm
building with my sister a digitally
native vertical baby brand hinge which
is a dating company and didn't even have
time to update the slide but a brand
called air Ayr comm which is a women's
brand that we incubated inside bonobos
and spun out and then I've invested both
personally and through a fund called red
swan in a bunch of other companies about
this point about fifty other companies
where I get to be an angel investor and
it's a privilege by the way I don't
recommend doing this it's not that
focused there's a lot going on and so I
talk a lot about getting one thing right
if you want to get something off the
ground what you want to do is get one
product right and so one of the things
that I've written about if you want to
raise money build a great product and
here's where I tip my cap to my
co-founder Brian's Bailey so this is a
product called the Turks and it was one
of our first products it was a pinwheel
lightweight corduroy it had a great
contrast pocketing liner it had the
curved waistband and we basically
launched bonobos behind eight styles
eight different colors of this pinwheel
corduroy product that was all we had and
on just that product this is what we did
so we got to about fifty thousand run
rate selling corduroy pants to our
friends at Stanford and when you have a
few thousand dollars from selling stuff
to your friends you have nice friends
but when you have fifty thousand dollars
and you're not selling drugs you might
have a business and so what you want to
see is can you get to can you get to
$50,000 of trailing revenue in about six
months and if you're doing that then
maybe you're onto something and
obviously if you're building an
enterprise software company or a SAS
company that doesn't apply but we're at
hustle con where a lot of us are trying
to build physical products we're trying
to build things that exist in the real
world it's not a conference aimed at
people who are doing technical software
driven
products see if you can get to $50,000
and at that point go try to raise money
don't necessarily try to raise money
beforehand and if the question is well
how do I do this you've got to find
enough money somewhere for inventory but
if you can't shake down you know $20,000
out of your rich aunt or if you can't
find a way to get that first little slug
of capital from somewhere
you're probably unlikely to get to that
second step when you're talking to
people who maybe aren't related to you
and so what you're going to discover is
a concept that might one of my friends
who's an entrepreneur his grandmother
used to call supply as infinite you know
there is an infinite supply of capital
in this world the number of rich people
in this world is staggering it's one of
the the smallest problems we have with
society we don't have too many rich
people we have plenty it's a good thing
because rich people can do things like
make investment and investment from a
macroeconomic perspective is what drives
our economy and so when you take the
perspective that just because someone
said no doesn't mean that everyone's
going to say no it probably just means
that like 53 more people are going to
say no before someone says yes and so
you have to have their resilience and
tenacity to power through that and the
magnetism self-belief to keep going but
just keep going don't worry I think
literally a thousand people have said no
to me on the way of bonobos we raise our
first eight million dollars from a
hundred and four people because we had
zero institutional capital support and
then one day in 2010 for whatever reason
the universe changed we were three years
into it I saw two venture capital firms
that were making investments in
e-commerce one called Excel who invested
in ModCloth another one called
Lightspeed who invested in ShoeDazzle
and later honest company and those
became our venture capital firms but
that was after three years of taking the
perspective that supply is infinite in
virtually every venture capital round
we've raised it bonobos has required
this tremendous sense that we're going
to find it somewhere in this face of a
significant amount of rejection okay so
now you've got a product that works
you've got the four qualities that are
required and you've got money
how do you build a great culture I think
building a great culture is a little bit
like making a Mexican male and so
somewhere in here just pretend like you
saw a slide about male it's got all
these ingredients that are really hard
to figure out you know it's like if
you've ever had a good mole a it takes
like 20 to 25 ingredients and so if it
tastes bad you don't know why and so
most companies don't have a good culture
mostly they're bad but no one knows why
but everyone talks about why culture
matters and why they want a great
culture and frequently they lie to
themselves about having a great culture
and so one of the only ways to figure it
out is you got to look at employee
engagement scores and you've got to be
willing to talk to people who are at the
ground level in your organization and
you've got to look at turnover and
you've got to look at your ratings on
Glassdoor and you have to internalize
all these problems as your own which I
call it's all your fault you know
founding CEO is a beautiful job because
everything is your fault
it's not even like being a US president
where you can just bring blame it on the
last person founding CEO you started the
company so it's all your fault so how do
you make a great culture in my opinion
it starts with having a mission and a
vision that people understand and so at
our company we have this brand story and
purpose that we talk about the evolution
of mankind starting with pants and
saying you know what we have great fit
and we have great customer service but
how do we actually have a story about
what we're doing that matters more we
reinvented the fit of a men's pant we've
now brought that two great shirts and
suits with products like our daily grind
dress shirt which we're about to release
with an amazing foolproof elbow and
that's got the same kind of concept of
fit or the jetsetter suit and then by
the way we don't think traditional
retail stores work so we're going to
reinvent that what might we reinvent
next and bringing that sense of passion
for a mission as the number one hiring
criteria in making sure people care
about this so how do you test it the way
that you tested in my opinion is you
make someone to offers you offer them
one cash offer with more stock and then
you offer them higher cash with lower
stock and if they go for higher cash and
lower stock you try to talk them out of
taking the job the second thing that you
need to do is figure out if they're
aligned with your core virtues or core
values so we have bonobos talk about
these five core virtues about human
values that we look for are you positive
do you put more goodwill than you take
out doesn't have to mean you're
gregarious or sociable you can be a
positive introvert you can feel it in
someone's spirit usually I can tell
right at the beginning of meeting
someone do they have positive energy
the second is intellectual honesty I
like to ask people in interviews when's
the last time you change your mind or
what's the thing that you most
passionately believed at one point in
your life that you no longer believe if
someone sits there and goes I don't know
probably not someone you want to hire
you need people who can look at data and
change their minds judgment the best way
to evaluate judgment is all the
decisions someone has made in their life
up until the moment that you've met them
you can usually tell if someone has
judged good judgment just from looking
at LinkedIn does their career make sense
are they making good decisions about
where they go judgement is about do you
make good decisions in the face of
uncertainty you don't even need to meet
someone to figure out if they have good
judgment empathy do they think about the
world from the perspective of other
people you know most of us spend our
lives inside our own heads it's
remarkable how little other people
actually care about us and yet we assume
they do most of us are spending 99% of
our energy thinking about ourselves and
so just the ability to carve off maybe
20% of your energy and imagine it from
the world of the perspective of others
this is what bonobos teach us although
they have less language capabilities
supposedly they're more empathetic and
they're less there they're more likely
to be imagining that world which is
incredible thing to think about
and then lastly self-awareness you know
it's sad but the research shows that
other being other than being tall white
and male and named John the highest
criteria of fortune 500 CEOs are two
things the ability to make good
analogies and being self-aware and
Daniel Goleman has written an amazing
article about this called self-awareness
what makes a leader which is if you want
to cultivate the one thing that you can
control that is likely to make you a
great leader its self-awareness it's the
ability to be
non-defensive about the things about you
that suck to understand your weaknesses
and to be able to talk about them with
other people in the room and then to own
your power own your strengths to be
unafraid of it these are the five
ingredients that we look for at bonobos
and most importantly we fire on these
five core values so you try to hire on
them but you're frequently going to get
it wrong or I should say you're not
infrequently going to get it wrong
hopefully you get it right most of the
time but when you don't as they say at
Netflix adequate performance has to get
generous severance and performance has
to be cultural performance as well and
ultimately you want to hire people that
know what they're doing you can't hire
someone to be lead violin who's not a
violinist but my belief is you hire for
passion for the mission and fit with
your core human values above experience
usually you're hiring someone who's
about to do it rather than someone who's
just done it and I think ultimately this
is the most elegant challenge in
business which is can you build a
company that is loved by your employees
because if your company is loved by your
employees shareholders are going to be
happy and customers are going to be
happy too
no one likes to work at a company where
the customers don't like the product or
the service or the bundle thereof and no
company ever thrives that has got a
great culture and that's not serving
customers well so I think that what Wall
Street would like to teach us as
shareholders come first customer second
employees come third and I would suggest
that we should invert that put employees
the top do a phenomenal job with that of
course they will serve customers well
and then shareholders will be taken care
of and by the way your employees are the
only people who are thinking about what
you do every day they're investing their
entire livelihoods outside of their
families where as a customer might think
about you once a day if you're lucky and
your shareholder thinks about you a lot
when the quarterly earnings come out and
so when it comes to leadership I would
suggest taking the opposite perspective
of Charles DeGaulle
which is what I want to know what France
thinks I ask myself and instead take the
perspective of an Eastern philosopher
Lao sue who says a leader is best when
people barely know he exists when his
work is done
his aim fulfilled they will say we did
it ourselves
and so if you've had some success now
what to do
don't become annoying don't let success
get to your head and I take this next
section as advice for myself right which
is that there's this pernicious force in
human nature which is hubris and it
comes with success don't let your feet
leave the ground keep it firmly planted
remember that everything that you've
done the further along you get has less
and less to do with you and more and
more to the people that you are tracking
to your venture and who are doing
incredible work you are doing less and
less and less and less and less over
time so you have less and less to your
credit as time goes on and be a weary of
the stories in human history and in
human mythology about what happens when
your feet do leave the ground this is a
picture of Kendrick Lamar who wrote a
great song on his Emmy winning winning
album that talks about a beggar and how
that beggar might actually be God and I
love that song because it's a mental
trick which is just because you're
quote/unquote powerful and someone else
is powerless doesn't mean that it should
change anything about your kindness
toward them and if you want to hear a
great song that will make you think and
really kind of trip you out consider
that other people who are successful and
powerful are precisely the people that
you need be the least concerned about
and the people who have not had the
privilege that you've had you must think
of in the inverse way be forgiving to
yourself this is a tough clicker but I'm
going to get it be forgiving to yourself
by being forgiving to others you're
going to make huge mistakes so you have
to learn to forgive yourself and you'll
learn to do the same thing to others
this becomes particularly important as a
boss you're the shepherd of the way that
other people feel about their
performance and then lastly a tribute to
my mom practice good judgment without
being judgmental and I learned that from
you mom so please one more round of
applause for the leader who I most
admire
and the final thing I have to say before
just maybe some brief questions is my
favorite poem on resilience and it's
called never give up it's by the Dalai
Lama never give up no matter what is
going on
never give up develop the heart too much
energy in your country is spent
developing the mind instead of the heart
I think he means America be
compassionate not just to your friends
but to everyone be compassionate work
for peace in your heart and in the world
work for peace and I say again never
give up no matter what is happening no
matter what is happening around you
never give up and I was on the phone
with my sister this morning she's
working through a fund raise for her
company Monica and Andy it's every bit
as tough as all the fund raises that
I've ever been through and I've been
through eight and I said it's like a
journey song don't stop believin and as
long as you believe in yourself you'll
get it done thank you very much
and we have time for like two to three
questions if people want to come down I
actually have a question myself huge
nose customer thing I've like 16 pairs
it's kind of weird but one thing you
didn't you kind of touched on didn't
really talk about a lot yes I think you
guys have fantastic customer service I
know that's becoming kind of a thing
where people are starting to realize
that it's really important there's a lot
of tools out there that help you you
know be really efficient when it comes
to customer service but what's your kind
of stance on the importance of that and
from a brand perspective I think it's if
you look at just our so our Net Promoter
Score now is running around 80 and if
you look at just our clothing products
we're going to be between 50 and 65
depending on the product so we're adding
somewhere between 15 and 30 points just
from customer service and it's the
ninjas and the guide shops so part of
the reason why I'm so bullish on
digitally native vertical brands like
bonobos and like Warby and like this
whole ecosystem is that you can
fundamentally bundle service together
with assortment and we found that it
comes in three ways it's about the right
technology enablement of service so
fewer contacts you actually want to
drive down your contacts per order
through great web and mobile experience
it's about having great online service
which in our case is the ninjas who if
you look at the ninjas they have an NPS
of 90 and then now it's about the
offline and having the offline have less
inventory management and more customer
service so I think it's a huge part of
the whole experience thanks for the
question you mentioned earlier once you
hit the fifty thousand dollar run rate
may be time to start raising some money
your thoughts on bootstrapping versus
raising I think they both are extremely
viable paths I think that if you have an
ambition to control your own destiny
more fully and your instincts are you
want to kind of keep it and maybe have
it for longer and have higher percent
ownership I think that bootstrapping can
be a phenomenal path I think that
raising capital is if you start to get
wider eyes about the opportunity and you
want to accelerate but I think both are
unbelievably viable ways to build
something and I think where you get into
trouble is where you end up doing
something that's inauthentic so I've
seen a friend of mine who started a
business raise capital forward even
though he's really a bootstrapper by
heart and he was miserable right because
of that pressure
that expectation and I've seen the flip
of it which is someone that really
wanted to go for it and they couldn't
raise capital and they were miserable by
that so I think you've got to look for
that authentic all comes back to
authenticity thank you thank you hi - my
name is George thanks I George ID what's
up man
my company cotton brew we make menswear
and we're in the process of starting the
fundraising and you know we want to
reach out to angels and you know you
mentioned you guys raised from know over
100 angels initially what would you
recommend as far as finding a relevant
angel so yeah chat to them and scalably
it's two things so 99.9% of Angels don't
want to invest in your company it's just
kind of a way to think about any company
so you got to find that point one
percent and I think the number one
fadeaway to find the point one percent
is people who've invested in similar
comes similar kinds of companies because
then you don't have to filter for will
they do a consumer retail investment
will they do a consumer retail menswear
investment that's number one and then
number two I think the best source of
angel investor recommendations is other
entrepreneurs who say those angels are
good so whenever you meet an
entrepreneur say hey do you have any
angel investors that you really like
right down the right down those names
and then ask them would you be open to
making an intro let me send you my
presentation or let me share with you
what I'm doing would you be open to
seeing if that angel investor wants to
meet me okay thank you
good luck hi my name is Jeanette kusik I
am the founder of the shopping service
Villard it's an iOS app we are just
before we have reached on product market
fit then we're about to grow what is
your key advice when it comes to growing
and scaling in terms of customer base
you know I I had a moment at bonobos
where we had product market fit and I
thought I was done and then I realized
that there was this other part which is
customers in growing customers in this
whole challenge of customer acquisition
and I think that one of the mistakes
that I made was assuming that doing more
marketing would help me grow product
market fit to equaling more revenue and
what I've learned is sometimes if you're
not seeing the business take off in a
more organic way it means that your
product market fit is not a 10x the next
product and so bonobos spent
for years growing the business quite
nicely but really by spending money on
marketing through venture capital in a
way that wasn't actually great from a
long-term perspective and it wasn't
until we invented the guide shop model
and did the partnership with our
phenomenal partners at Nordstrom and
started developing a print catalog in
doing some kind of contrarian things for
a digital brand that we really took off
and so sometimes you have to think about
your product experience as being
something you want to extend into new
categories and new channels rather than
just marketing the existing bundle of
product and market that you have thank
you I think we found the same way we did
some Facebook and Instagram marketing in
the beginning and when we didn't have
more funding for that we had to kind of
be more it gets not about it gets
expensive right thank you very much
and nokton and not smart enough either
yes thank you Thank You private all the
time we have thank you thanks so much
everybody thank you thanks man